Kai first of all tell me where are you
talking to us from where are you right
now in the world I'm calling from a
small fishing Village on the coast of
Norway on the islands of lufoten called
egum I'm sorry it's called flu fluten
yeah
oh I'm sorry how foolish of me
your name is Kai and you're coming from
Lou fleuten
Norway yes
let him say it one more time say it
again
I think you're getting it
um you're coming along it's nice
Kai tell me a little bit about yourself
who are you tell us about Kai uh I am
just the run of the old male fish farmer
from Norway I uh I used to be a
fisherman
uh I don't know if you've seen like the
Discovery Channels TV show Deadliest
Catch yes so you used to be a used to be
a fisherman you used to take fish from
the sea but now you're a fish farmer
which means that you are planting fish
in the ground in the ground fish seeds
how does it work like it's it's funny
because like the fishermen don't really
like the fish Farmers that much because
they think it's cheating but I just say
to the fishermen which I used to be
myself that why do you want to go out
into the ocean and spend a lot of time
searching for fish when you can just
plant in there feed them and sell them
when they get big yeah that's true and
so how does that go over with the
fishermen yeah no they're angry all the
time I think they're pretty angry when
you say that uh you're fish farming but
that still means you get in a boat yes
you get in a boat and you go out and you
have an area where you where you raise
these fish yeah we have like these
installations on the ocean called a fish
cage and uh like where I work we have 10
of them and there's about 500 000 salmon
in these cages and we go out on Arcadium
around every day and we like make sure
it gets fed we make sure like the
temperatures are like the environment is
right around them and stuff like that
yeah what do you feed the salmon yeah
it's something called pellets it's like
this it's something like they have
figured out the kind of uh of uh of food
that it gets to like make them grow the
most from what they eat right so it's is
it filled with lots of chemicals and
stuff uh that will help you no no
chemicals it's
like me it's all natural okay oh very
nice oh I don't know about yukai but I
rely on many chemicals to enhance things
if you know what I mean and you will uh
Kai you will what Kai please settle down
gang Kai
um do fish would if you fed salmon
hamburger would they eat it of course we
wouldn't
good answer I'm just curious like part
of me thinks wouldn't it be funny to
feed salmon hamburger and then feed that
to a pescetarian and then when they're
done go ha ha you just ate a lot of
hamburger you wouldn't that be a
fun prank
yeah that would be yeah that would be
hilarious
I'm writing it down as we speak in an
increasingly competitive job market it's
important to make sure your brand stands
out from the crowd that is important
Sona yeah that's right vegan cupcakes
from your kitchen or marketing your
wedding photography business I'm just
making these up yeah I can tell
Squarespace helps you create a modern
platform through engaging and
aesthetically pleasing online presence
that's important if things look nice
people will buy with member areas you
can unlock a new Revenue stream for your
business and free up time in your
schedule by selling access to gated
content like videos online courses or
newsletters newsletters yeah stand out
in any inbox with email from Squarespace
email campaigns collect email
subscribers and convert them into loyal
customers social just play posts from
your social profiles on your website
analytics you want to hear more I'll
give you some use insights to grow your
business learn where your site visits
and sales are coming from and analyze
which channels are most effective good
heavens and the Lord above head to
squarespace.com
free trial when you're ready to launch
use offer code Conan to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or domain do
you like your job do you like going out
on the sea and and working with these
fish is is that what kind of life is
that and do you enjoy it
it's it's it's
amazing it's I think when I picture my
life I think if I get to stay within
this field of work I'm gonna die happy
man because it's it's such a free type
of job you know where uh we're just too
like we're colleagues but basically
we're really good friends going out on a
boat doing our thing we don't really
have like super viruses hanging over us
we it's like the ocean breeze it's the
weather it's everything around that and
like at the end of the day when we when
we come in we can put a good honest days
work behind us you know it's interesting
you say that because it sounds like
you're a real man's man
I am a real man yeah look at me no no I
know what I'm saying without without
kidding around you're this is you're
going out on the sea to to make your way
to make your living there's high winds
it's very dramatic off Norway and you're
a real man doing this
uh work yeah that's like an honest day's
labor I'm kind of envious yeah because
you well I'm not envious because
Kai what I do is very similar no no I
come out here I don't know if the if the
temperature in the podcast Booth is
going to be 71 or 72. I don't know if my
if the iced tea they got me is going to
be completely unsweetened or have a
little bit of sugar so I too am battling
the elements in my own way absolutely
I'm so happy that I'm up here in the in
the Arctic and not down there it's I'm
so glad you're what you just said so so
Kai you're just very happy that you're
that you're you and not me is that what
you're saying yeah yeah that's sort of
what I'm saying I can't imagine
prepare those problems no um well you
you mentioned that you go out
with someone else who is this is this a
brother is it a friend who do you go out
who's your colleague well it's uh I
would rather say that he's a colleague
or like kiss a buddy more than a
colleague because we're searching
friends and his name is like in
Norwegian his name is pronounced
and uh
his name is guard Seaman yeah that's
yeah it's it's guard semen and it's the
perfect name for a guy who works in the
ocean
no it's not actually that would be jack
fish or Billy wave it's the perfect name
for someone who wants to have a prison
guard for a child yeah I mean guard
semen is not I don't think of as the
perfect ocean-going name does he tell
people his name is guard semen not if
they're English no yeah yeah he should
switch it to Gus jizz
[Laughter]
just saying if you tell him if he comes
to like the United States make sure he
says Gus jizz you don't want people
getting the wrong idea okay
I'll be sure to tell them that tomorrow
when he basically kicks my ass yeah all
right so your friend guard Seaman uh AKA
Gus jizz uh he goes out on the boat with
you every day
I would think two guys out on a
relatively small boat on a vast ocean
together
uh do you guys ever do you get along I
mean because that would wear on me for a
while and I I love oh wait a minute I'm
not just seeing who's in the booth with
me yeah well no what I'm saying is I do
like you guys I like I like getting on a
boat with you I like Matt Gourley and I
and I like son of obsession but if we
were on a small boat together every day
no we we would last maybe half an hour
no how do you guys get along well the
thing is that to keep it fresh we have
installed this this fun game we do when
we're out in the ocean we put on this
like local radio channel which is called
radio Retro so it plays like hits from
the 60s to the 90s and we have it on
full volume so when we're out working
whenever there's a song comes on the
first one to guess like the band's name
or or the like title of the song gets a
point
and that's like the way we'd like to
keep it fresh so it's a competition all
throughout the day but you do that every
day every day there's two of you bobbing
in the water and then one of you shouts
out it's the Archies Sugar Sugar and you
high-five each other that's that's
what's keeping this together
yeah
when you say it like that you know uh
yeah well don't you make him don't make
him question this that's all he's got no
what do you mean when I say it like that
uh Kai that's what it is when you say it
like that when you guessed the song and
then you have to listen to the whole
song yeah yeah that's the best part Thin
Lizzy Boys Are Back In Town you got
another one
jizz
[Laughter]